This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗逆力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 2。可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手交往过时，她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看当年》播客中。对 1979 年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而进》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临着
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. If you have been around for a little while, you might remember that at the start of each year, I kind of like to set a theme for the next 12 months to come as part of like our welcome to the new year like podcast series that I do every new year. For 2025,
后果。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理学。如果你关注了一段时间，你可能还记得，在每年年初，我都有点喜欢为接下来的 12 个月设定一个主题，作为我每年新年所做的“迎接新年”播客系列的一部分。对于 2025 年，
this year's intention, it was the year for trusting yourself, which to me I think really meant like letting yourself be a little bit afraid, trusting yourself in situations you haven't been before, honoring your intuition amongst many other things. And today, I wanted to kind of return to that new year pledge and do like a check in for like the final, what is it, like final third of the year. I'll be honest. And I said this in the initial episode. Trusting myself is something I've always struggled with. I can think of so many moments where I knew deep down what was the right decision for me. but I still asked five other people what they thought, or I still hesitated. Everything from when I wanted to break up with my first boyfriend to literally like the other
今年的初心，是相信自己的一年，在我看来，这真的意味着允许自己感到一点害怕，在以前没有经历过的情境中相信自己，在众多事情中尊重自己的直觉。今天，我想回归那个新年的誓言，做一个盘点，针对最后，是什么来着，最后三分之一的年景。老实说。我在最初的那一集里也说过。相信自己一直是我一直在挣扎的事情。我能想起无数个瞬间，我内心深处明明知道什么对我是正确的决定。但我还是问了其他五个人的想法，或者我还是犹豫了。从我想和我的第一个男朋友分手，到字面意义上的像另一
week I was at IKEA and I was like trying to decide what lamp to buy. This like opinion shopping that I often do either leads me to an outcome that I don't really want, not because of the other people but because of me or it takes me so much longer to act on things that were pretty emotionally in time sensitive. And later on, I look back and I think, why did I not just listen to myself? Like, in hindsight, it was so clear what I wanted. It was so clear what I was being called to do. And I just didn't have that sense of trust that I actually was making the right decision
周我在宜家，我当时在纠结该买哪盏灯。这种所谓的“意见购物”往往导致我走向一个我并不是真的很想要的结果，不是因为别人，而是因为我自己，或者它让我对那些在情感上具有时间紧迫性的事情花多得多的时间去采取行动。后来，我回过头来想，我为什么就不能听我自己的呢？就像，事后看来，我想要什么非常清楚。我被召唤去做什么非常清楚。而我只是没有那种信任感，觉得我实际上在做正确的决定
or that I could trust my intuition. Maybe you have been here too, that kind of, like the tug of war between your own instincts and the pressure of outside voices. it's definitely not easy, especially in your 20s, when I feel like we'd all just love for someone to give us the answer and to like kind of play your life for you, like a video game. But what I've learnt is that trusting yourself doesn't actually mean you're always going to get it right, the same way that if you put someone else in charge of your life,
或者我可以相信自己的直觉。也许你也曾有过这样的经历，那种介于你自己的直觉和外界声音的压力之间的拉锯战。这绝对不容易，尤其是在你二十岁的时候，我觉得我们所有人都很希望有人能给我们答案，并像玩电子游戏一样帮你度过一生。但我学到的是，相信自己并不意味着你总能做对，就像如果你把另一个人放在掌控你生活的位置上，
they wouldn't always get it right either. It doesn't guarantee an outcome. What it really does is just give a sense of, I trust myself, which means I'm going to be fine anyways. And as I always say, the opposite of anxiety isn't calm. It's actually trust. So building that internal anchor and that internal system and process is like one of the most crucial things that we can do during this decade. So in today's episode, we're going to dive into why self-trust is honestly so hard, how trust can be the antidote to a lot of innate fears that this decade of life brings up for us.
他们也不可能总是做对。它不能保证结果。它真正做到的只是给人一种“我相信自己，这意味着我无论如何都会好起来的”感觉。正如我常说的，焦虑的反义词不是平静。其实是信任。因此，建立这种内在的锚、内在的系统和过程，是我们在这个十年里能做的最关键的事情之一。所以在今天的节目中，我们将深入探讨为什么自信老实说这么难，信任如何能够成为这十年生活带给我们的许多固有恐惧的解药，
and how we can kind of rebuild the connection with our, this inner voice that we all have, even if you can't hear it very clearly right now, how can we rebuild that relationship using some essential psychology tools? I really hope that you guys enjoy this episode because if there's one relationship that's going to carry you through life, it is the one you have with yourself. And learning to trust that person, the one who will make every decision for you, be with you for every outcome, see you through every setback. that is going to make you feel a lot more capable.
以及我们如何能够重新建立与我们的联系，我们所有人都有的这个内心的声音，即使你现在听不太清楚，我们如何能利用一些基本的心理学工具重建这种关系？我真的很希望你们喜欢这一集，因为如果说有一段关系将伴随你一生，那就是你与自己的关系。学会信任那个人，那个将为你做出每一个决定、陪你经历每一个结果、陪你走过每一个挫折的人。那会让你觉得自己更有能力。
So without further ado, let's get into how we can fully trust ourselves. Trust is one of those words. We, I think, tend to place in the hands of others a lot. You know, we talk about whether we can, like, trust our friends, whether our partners are trustworthy, whether, like, the people we've worked with have, like, gained our confidence, whether we can, like, trust politicians. trust is like this leap of faith for another person where if you're wrong, you can obviously
废话不多说，让我们进入如何完全信任自己。信任就是那种词。我们，我想，往往倾向于把信任放在别人手中。你知道，我们讨论我们是否可以，比如，信任我们的朋友，我们的伴侣是否值得信赖，比如，我们共事过的人是否，比如，赢得了我们的信任，我们是否可以，比如，信任政治家。信任就像是对另一个人的信仰之跃，如果你错了，你显然会
fall pretty far. But the deeper, more unsettling question that's often left unasked is, do I trust myself? Not only do I trust myself in my judgments of those people, but do I actually believe that I can rely on my own judgment, my own instincts, my own ability to handle whatever life is going to bring me? Or is it the case that I kind of hide behind other people's opinions, hide behind indecision, hide behind kind of doing nothing? For many of us, especially in our 20s, you know, the answer is we probably don't trust ourselves fully. I, at least I go back and forth, sometimes feeling like I'm so in my element, I'm so prepared for whatever, whatever happens in life. and other times, like, just really feeling like the wind could blow me over.
跌得很惨。但更深层、更令人不安的问题往往没有被问及，那就是：我信任自己吗？不仅是我在对这些人的判断中信任自己，而且我真的相信我可以依赖我自己的判断、我自己的直觉、我自己应对生活带给我的任何事情的能力吗？还是说我有点躲在别人的意见后面、躲在优柔寡断后面、躲在什么都不做后面？对我们许多人来说，尤其是在我们二十岁的时候，你知道，答案是我们可能并不完全信任自己。我，至少我摇摆不定，有时觉得我完全掌控了一切，我已经准备好应对生活中发生的任何事情。而另有的时候，就真的感觉风一吹就能把我刮倒。
And that's not because we're weak or incapable. It's because our 20s are, like, uniquely challenging to this self-trust. We've talked about this term before, emerging adulthood. This is a term that was coined by the developmental psychologist, Jeffrey Arnett, and he uses it to describe how uniquely tumultuous this period of our lives is and how we are kind of playing what he calls a, roleless role, often shifting by hour, by day, by week between different perspectives and essentially different versions of ourselves and trying to find the right ones or one against
这不是因为我们软弱或无能。这是因为我们的二十岁对这种自信提出了独特的挑战。我们以前讨论过这个词，成年早期。这是发展心理学家杰弗里·阿内特（Jeffrey Arnett）创造的一个词，他用它来描述我们生命中这个时期是多么的独特而动荡，以及我们是如何在扮演他所说的“无角色的角色”，经常按小时、按天、按周在不同的视角之间以及本质上在不同版本的自己之间转换，并试图在
like the backdrop of some pretty life-defining choices, meaning that you are sometimes going to make wrong choices according to the future version of you. Sometimes you're going to make wrong choices that later on you might regret. That doesn't mean you can't trust yourself. It means that you made the best decision at the time with what you knew now and you made the best decision at the time with the identity that you thought was most true to yourself. But that doesn't always help. We don't always have that perspective. We can actually be rather cruel to our past selves and about the decisions that we're currently making. And it means that we can feel kind of alienated from our own selves. Like, why did I think that was a good idea? You know,
一些相当定义人生的选择的背景下找到正确的一个或几个，这意味着根据未来版本的你，你有时会做出错误的决定。有时你会做出错误的决定，后来你可能会后悔。这并不意味着你不能相信自己。这意味着你在当时根据你当时所知做出了最好的决定，并且你在当时根据你认为最真实的自我认同做出了最好的决定。但这并不总是管用。我们并不总是拥有那种视角。我们实际上对过去的自己以及我们目前正在做出的决定相当残酷。这意味着我们会对我们自己感到某种程度的疏离。比如，我怎么会认为那是个好主意呢？你知道，
How did I end up here? Why did I think that was a good decision? That's like a classic thing in our 20s, especially as we get into our later 20s of like, wow, why did I wear that? Why did I date that person? Why did I say that thing? Why did I take that job?
我怎么会落到这一步？为什么我认为那是个好决定？这在我们二十岁时是个经典现象，尤其是当我们进入二十岁后期的时候，比如，天哪，我当时为什么要穿那个？我为什么跟那个人约会？我为什么说那句话？我为什么接受那份工作？
Not remembering that, you know, at the time, that's what felt like the right thing to do. It's all part of it. There's also this undercurrent of fear and kind of like what if thinking that definitely stalks a lot of the decisions that we're making. This really does injure our self-trust because we're constantly thinking, you know, what if I'm wrong right now? What if I can't handle the consequences? What if, you know, this one choice and the 10 years of choices that it leads me to mean that I end up having a lot of regrets or I regret my life as a whole?
不记得，你知道，在当时，这感觉是正确的事情。这都是其中的一部分。其中还存在着一种恐惧的暗流和诸如“如果……会怎样”的想法，这绝对困扰着我们正在做出的许多决定。这确实损害了我们的自信，因为我们不断地在想，你知道，如果我现在错了怎么办？如果我无法应对后果怎么办？如果，你知道的，这一个选择以及它带给我的未来十年的选择意味着我最终会有很多遗憾，或者我后悔我的一生怎么办？
That's a classic for me, feeling like I can't trust myself right now because I don't have certainty around how the decision I'm currently making is going to like impact. me in the future. And I'm sure a lot of us are very familiar with this. I think one of the most paralyzing experiences of our 20s is just this general anxiety we have about the future. Someone said this to me the other day and I love it. Anxiety basically thrives in the gap between what we can't control and what we think we can't handle. If the world is uncertain and spoiler alert it is and your brain believes you're helpless, which you're not, anxiety has a lot of room to operate. You're not helpless, even if you do end up making a few wrong choices, even if you do have moments of fear. Literally there are people who come back from hugely
这对我来说是个典型情况，觉得自己现在不能相信自己，因为我对目前正在做出的决定将如何影响。我未来的发展没有确定性。我相信我们许多人对此都非常熟悉。我认为二十岁时最让人麻木的经历之一，就是我们对未来普遍存在的这种焦虑。前几天有人对我说过这句话，我非常喜欢。焦虑基本上在“我们无法控制的事情”与“我们认为自己无法应对的事情”之间的鸿沟中滋生。如果世界是不确定的（剧透警告：确实如此），而你的大脑认为你是无能为力的（其实你并非如此），焦虑就会有很大的运作空间。你并不是无能为力，即使你最终确实做出了几个错误的决定，即使你确实有过恐惧的时刻。真的有人从那些极具
destructive life-altering decisions and still live out incredible lives. You will as well. I know this probably won't do much to ease your anxiety though, and that's because cognitive behavioral models of anxiety really talk about how there is this vicious cycle when it comes to our lack of trust in the future. Anxious people, I count myself as one of them, we constantly overestimate the threats in the environment or in the future whilst also underestimating our own ability to cope. And because we seriously do not acknowledge how much power we really have and how much resilience we really have, it just feels like anything we catastrophize about, any big life altering thing we can imagine, each of them could just be the end of us.
破坏性、改变人生的决定中走出来，依然过着令人难以置信的生活。你也会的。我知道这可能对缓解你的焦虑无济于事，那是因为焦虑的认知行为模型确实在谈论当我们对未来缺乏信任时，存在着这样一个恶性循环。焦虑的人（我把自己算作其中之一），我们不断高估环境或未来的威胁，同时又低估了我们自己的应对能力。而且因为我们严重没有承认我们真正拥有多少力量以及我们真正拥有多少韧性，这只会让人觉得我们灾难化想象的任何事情，我们能想象到的任何改变人生的重大事情，每一件都可能成为我们的末日。
And we don't give ourselves enough credit for the fact that we will probably be okay. Not only will a lot of that stuff probably not happen, but you are a lot more capable in those times of crisis or even in those times of just like a little bit of negativity than you think you are. The antidote to that spiral, of course, is once again self-trust. and that's sometimes the thing that feels the hardest in those moments, but it is the truest anchor you can find. A recent study, I think it was conducted last year at a university in South Korea, looked at around 800 participants, and it looked at what the most effective emotional antidote to anxiety was. They looked at things like hope. They looked at things like happiness. They looked at things like trust. And what they found was not only did trust actually end up in,
而且我们没有给自己足够的认可，那就是我们很可能最终会没事的。不仅很多那种事情可能不会发生，而且你在危机时刻，甚至在仅仅有一点点负面情绪的时刻，都比你想象的更有能力。这种螺旋式上升的解药，当然，还是自我信任。而这有时恰恰是那些时刻感觉最难做到的事情，但它却是你能找到的最真实的锚。最近的一项研究，我想这是去年在韩国的一所大学进行的，调查了大约 800 名参与者，研究了焦虑最有效的心理情绪解药是什么。他们研究了诸如希望之类的事情。他们研究了诸如幸福之类的事情。他们研究了诸如信任之类的事情。他们的发现不仅是信任最终能够，
improving hope and improving happiness and reducing anxiety, but self-trust in particular was most influential compared to trust in others or trust in an organisation or a trust in a God or a religion. Self-trust, which was basically measured by like confidence in our abilities, belief in our abilities, self-respect. It was the most influential thing measured in this study for improving anxiety. And yet, I don't think it gets mentioned much in the literature. When you trust yourself, I think the secondary thing that we've kind of been coming to is that you stop needing certainty and outcomes, which you're never going to find anyways. You know, you don't have to know exactly how a situation will unfold because you know you can handle it. So it takes a lot of the worry away.
提升希望、提升幸福感并减少焦虑，而且与其他人的信任、对机构的信任、或是对上帝或宗教的信任相比，尤其是自我信任最具影响力。自我信任，基本上通过对我们能力的信心、对我们能力的信念、自尊来衡量。在这项研究中，它是改善焦虑最具影响力的因素。然而，我认为在文献中它很少被提及。当你相信自己时，我认为我们一直在逐渐接近的第二件事是，你不再需要确定性和结果，反正你永远也找不到这些。你知道，你不需要确切地知道一个局面将如何展开，因为你知道你能应付。所以它消除了很多担忧。
So often I think we get like swept up in this idea that the antidote to anxiety is control. If I could just predict or manage every possible outcome, well, I'd feel safe. If I just knew exactly how this situation would pan out, I wouldn't worry. And so control becomes kind of like a red herring that we are like constantly chasing, not realizing that it is entirely an illusion and what keeps us really deeply entrenched in an exhausting, anxious pattern of thinking. It is like looking for a pot of gold at the end of the rainbow. That's how I always think about it. Trust on the other hand, unlike certainty, is real. It is the rainbow. It is practical. It is.
通常我认为我们会被这样一种想法席卷，即焦虑的解药是控制。如果我能预测或管理每一种可能的结果，好吧，我就会感到安全。如果我只是确切地知道这种情况将如何发展，我就不会担心了。因此，控制变成了一种红鲱鱼，我们不断地在追逐它，却没有意识到它完全是一种幻觉，而正是这种幻觉让我们深深陷入一种令人筋疲力尽、焦虑的思维模式中。这就像在彩虹的尽头寻找一罐金子。我总是这样想的。另一方面，与确定性不同，信任是真实的。它就是彩虹。它是务实的。它是。
actionable and it turns the focus away from external to internal we no longer need the illusion of certainty or trying to seek reassurance from others to know that we'll be okay instead we can be really secure in the knowledge that whatever happens you're going to be okay and in that anxiety like it doesn't have anything left like it really loosens its grip because it's like okay maybe we can't predict when the army will attack but it doesn't matter because like my forces my emotional forces, my forces of resilience are super strong. So if self-trust is so vital, why do so many of us lack it? This is pretty multi-layered. I think the first reason is because, yes, there isn't that focus. It's also not taught. For some of us, you know, it's going to sound
可行的，它将焦点从外部转移到内部，我们不再需要确定性的幻觉或试图从他人那里寻求安慰来知道我们会好起来，相反，我们可以非常笃信这样一种认知：无论发生什么，你都会好起来的，而在此之中，焦虑——它就什么也不剩了——它真的放松了它的掌控，因为它就像，好吧，也许我们无法预测军队何时会进攻，但这没关系，因为像我的力量、我的情感力量、我的韧性力量超级强大。所以，如果自信如此重要，为什么我们当中有这么多人缺乏自信？这相当多层次。我认为第一个原因是，是的，没有那种关注。它也没有被教导。对我们中的一些人来说，你知道，这听起来会
so cliche, but it always does seem to stretch back to childhood. If you grew up in an environment where your opinions weren't respected, where you were shamed for your mistakes or your feelings were dismissed, you may have internalized the message that your instincts, your relationship to your emotions, you know, when you really do require help, like all of those messages can't be trusted. Eric Erickson, we talk about him, again, a lot. He's very famous. He developed the eight stages of psychosocial development back in the 50s. He basically, he basically, suggested and noted that of all the stages that we go through from when we're a child to when we're an adult, one of the most important ones is this trust versus mistrust stage.
如此陈词滥调，但它总是似乎可以追溯到童年。如果你在一个你的意见不被尊重、你因犯错而感到羞耻或你的感觉被驳回的环境中长大，你可能已经内化了这样一种信息：你的直觉、你与情绪的关系（当你确实需要帮助时），你知道，所有这些信息都是不可信的。埃里克·埃里克森（Eric Erickson），我们再次经常谈论他。他非常有名。他在 50 年代提出了心理社会发展的八个阶段。他基本上，他基本上，提出并指出，在我们从儿童到成人的所有阶段中，最重要的一阶段是这个信任与不信任的阶段。
This takes place like around 18 months to like two years old and according to him, this period is so crucial because it's when our view of the world and ourselves and our personalities and our abilities are really shaped. even if we don't have memory of that time, at this age, we know we are completely dependent on our caregivers. And so how our parents obviously interact with us has a big impact. Aspects that can really build a sense of trust are things like the caregiver creating a safe environment for us to make mistakes, or our caregivers being attentive to our needs, or offering readurance when we are scared or distressed, basically saying like, oh, you're having a reaction, you're having an emotion, you're having a feeling.
这个阶段大约发生在 18 个月到两岁左右，根据他的说法，这个时期如此关键，因为正是在这个时期，我们对世界、对自我、对个性和能力的看法真正成形。即使我们对那个时期没有记忆，在这个年龄，我们也知道我们完全依赖照顾者。因此，我们的父母显然如何与我们互动具有巨大的影响。能够真正建立信任感的方面包括：照顾者为我们创造一个安全的犯错环境，或者我们的照顾者对我们的需求保持专注，或者在我们害怕或痛苦时提供安慰，基本上就是说，哦，你有反应了，你有情绪了，你有感觉了。
well that must mean something and so by building trust in them and knowing that they're going to give that feeling attention or some kind of solution we also build trust in ourselves you know hopefully that kind of makes sense of course you know things wouldn't have been perfect all the time you know when a baby cries sometimes it is really hard to figure out what's wrong but it's really about whether the trustworthy relationships and interactions that we had outweighed the untrustworthy ones if the positive does outweigh the bad, then according to Erickson, this gives us, this gives infants a good sense of how to trust themselves as well and how to trust the world around them all through that primary relationship. However, if bad interactions outweigh the good, if untrustworthy
嗯，那一定意味着什么，因此通过建立对他们的信任，知道他们会给这种感觉以关注或某种解决方案，我们也建立对自己的信任，你知道，希望这有点说得通。当然，你知道，事情不可能一直都是完美的，你知道，当婴儿哭泣时，有时真的很难弄清楚出了什么问题，但关键真的在于我们拥有的值得信赖的关系和互动是否超过了不值得信赖的互动。如果积极的方面确实超过了糟糕的方面，那么根据埃里克森的说法，这赋予了，这让婴儿对如何相信自己以及如何相信他们周围的世界有了一个良好的感觉，这一切都通过那种主要的初级关系来实现。然而，如果糟糕的互动超过了好的互动，如果不值得信赖的
interactions outweigh the trustworthy ones, and you know, we as children haven't yet been able to rationalize why that may be, we instead, as he suggests, begin to internalize that completely. begin to turn inward, begin to believe we're unimportant, we're unlovable, and also that we can't trust those around us, we also can't trust ourselves, or we can only trust ourselves. We lean towards hyperindependence, which can actually be equally unhealthy because hyperindependence actually isn't necessarily about self-trust. It's again about control. Hyper independence is about feeling like the only person you can rely on is you because you don't trust yourself in situations where you do need like a broader set of skills. So I don't know if that makes sense.
互动超过了值得信赖的互动，并且你知道，我们作为儿童还不能理性地解释为什么会这样，正如他所建议的那样，我们反而开始将此完全内化。开始向内转，开始相信我们是不重要的、是不可爱的，而且我们也不能信任我们周围的人，我们也不能信任我们自己，或者我们只能信任我们自己。我们倾向于过度独立，这实际上可能同样不健康，因为过度独立实际上不一定关乎自信。它再次关乎控制。过度独立关乎这样一种感觉：唯一可以依靠的人就是你自己，因为你在需要更广泛技能组合的情况下不相信自己。所以，我不知道这讲不讲得通。
To me it definitely does and like I think about that. I'm like, yeah, that definitely sits. But it's just important to understand how like along the way think of trust as like this tree that needs to have really deep roots in order to stand tall in adulthood and, you know, in our 20s. And if at any point something has poisoned those roots or something has made you believe that this tree is shakeable, that you don't find support in the trunk of it, like, it's going to deeply injure you and harm you. Another significant element of this is perfectionism. You can really see that like what we're not we're not just talking about self-trust again we're talking about this competition between control and a reliance on ourselves at first i think perfectionism can actually
对我来说绝对讲得通，而且像我想的那样。我想，是的，那绝对切中要害。但这只是很重要，要去理解信任如何像这样一棵树，它需要有非常深的根基，才能在成年期和我们的二十岁时挺拔伫立。如果在这个过程中的任何时候，有什么东西毒害了这些根，或者有什么东西让你相信这棵树是不稳固的，你在它的树干中找不到支撑，那么，它会深深地伤害你。这其中的另一个重要因素是完美主义。你真的可以看出，我们谈论的不仅仅是自我信任，我们再次谈论的是控制与对自己的依赖之间的这种竞争。起初，我认为完美主义实际上可以
kind of seem like trust much like hyper independence right like we prove to ourselves that we are capable through pushing beyond what we imagine we strive for excellence and often this excellence is rewarded we prove that we can trust our abilities but if we believe our self-worth is conditional on never failing, every single mistake becomes proof that you can't trust yourself. And so you have to apply more pressure. You have to apply more force onto yourself to keep meeting your standard. This inner critic becomes a lot louder in your 20s when I think the stakes become a lot higher and you begin to feel an even greater sense of responsibility for your actions. Again, it's not about making the right decision that will continue to work out in the future forever or never. It's
有点像信任，就像过度独立一样，对吧？我们通过突破我们的想象来向自己证明我们有能力，我们追求卓越，而这种卓越往往会得到回报。我们证明我们可以相信自己的能力，但如果我们认为我们的自我价值是以从不失败为条件的，每一个错误都变成了你不能相信自己的证据。所以你必须施加更多的压力。你必须对自己施加更多力量来不断达到你的标准。在二十岁时，当你认为赌注变得更高，并且你开始对自己的行为感到更大的责任感时，这种内心的批判声音会变得大得多。再说一次，这不是关于做出一个能在未来继续永远奏效或永不奏效的正确决定。这
just about being able to make a decision at all. And often perfectionism is master's procrastination, which again is an indicator of a lack of self-trust. If you cannot make a decision because you do not have confirmation that everything isn't going to turn out absolutely perfectly how you would like it, you are going to procrastinate on that decision. You're going to experience major decision paralysis. That's your perfectionism at play. Again, it shows that deep down. You don't really think that you're capable of handling what might come if you can't predict or control the outcome from the get-go. I think also as a culture, we're also conditioned to outsource authority and that further kind of damages this tree or this compass or however you want to visualize it. You know,
只是关于能否做出一个决定。而且往往完美主义是拖延症的大师，这再次表明了缺乏自信。如果你无法做出一个决定，因为你没有得到证实，一切都不会完全按照你希望的那样完美地发展，你就会在这项决定上拖延。你会经历严重的决策瘫痪。这就是你的完美主义在起作用。再次说明，这表明在内心深处。如果你从一开始就无法预测或控制结果，你真的认为自己没有能力应对接下来可能发生的事情。我认为作为一个文化，我们也习惯了外包权威，这进一步损害了这棵树或这个指南针，或者无论你想怎么想象它。你知道，
algorithms these days, tell us what to buy. I don't know about you, but like, I'm just buying the first thing that shows up when I Google it. Like, I don't really like trust myself to know what I want sometimes. You know, career guides tell us what the best route is and what our dream job will be. Self-help books give us like the perfect formula if you can just bring yourself to follow it. You know, advice isn't bad in itself, but when we rely on it too much, we really do forget how to hear our own voice. And over time, the silence of that voice feels like it's absence when really it's just like waiting for us to tune back in. These external factors, perfectionism, childhood, outsourcing authority.
如今的算法告诉我们买什么。我不知道你们怎么样，但就像，我只是在谷歌搜索时买第一个出现的东西。有时，你知道，我真的不太相信自己能知道我想要什么。你知道，职业指南告诉我们哪条是最佳路线，什么将是我们的理想工作。自助书籍给我们提供了完美的公式，只要你能让自己去遵循它。你知道，建议本身并不是坏事，但当我们过于依赖它时，我们确实忘记了如何倾听我们自己的声音。随着时间的推移，那个声音的沉默感觉就像它的缺席，而实际上它只是在等待我们重新调频。这些外部因素、完美主义、童年、外包权威。
They all kind of play into each other to make it really difficult to break out and to just like come back to what is a deep human intuition that we all have. This is the other thing. Self-trust also means reconnecting with like a really ancient information system and a really ancient intuitive system that perhaps we've kind of forgotten and that perhaps we kind of don't have time to listen to because we are so busy because we are required to make such urgent choices because the stakes of this like modern day feel very fast intuition is not always going to be the most urgent voice in the room it might actually be the most calm.
它们都在某种程度上相互作用，使得打破僵局变得非常困难，并且只是回归到我们所有人都有的深刻的人类直觉。这是另一回事。自信也意味着重新连接一个非常古老的信息系统和一个非常古老直觉系统，也许我们有点遗忘了，也许我们有点没有时间去倾听，因为我们太忙了，因为我们被要求做出如此紧迫的选择，因为这种现代生活的赌注感觉非常快，直觉并不总是房间里最急迫的声音。它实际上可能是最平静的。
It might also need a little bit more time to rise to the surface. And I know that sounds counter to what you may expect or imagine intuition as, which is like that immediate reactional response to something happening in your environment that tells you that you're in danger. But the intuition we're talking about is like a sense of, like the intuition around a deeper sense of self. And I think in like a modern context, we don't, that intuitive sense of self doesn't have as much breathing room. And so of course, when we're constantly pushed into making quick,
它可能还需要更多的时间才能浮出水面。我知道这听起来与你可能期望或想象的直觉相反，直觉就像是对你环境中发生的事情的即时反应，告诉你你处于危险之中。但我们谈论的直觉就像是一种感觉，围绕着对自我的更深层理解的直觉。而且我认为在现代语境中，我们不，那种直觉上的自我意识没有那么多的喘息空间。所以当然，当我们不断被推向做出快速、
urgent decisions or wanting to outsource our decision making, again, that muscle, that self-trust muscle atrophies and continues to weaken. So we're going to talk about why that is, but also how we can rebuild that muscle, how we can re-hear, I don't know what, what's the right word, how we can I get I get to tune back into this like deep pool of self-knowledge and self-trust that we all innately have after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
紧迫的决定，或者想要外包我们的决策时，肌肉，那个自信的肌肉就会萎缩并继续变弱。所以我们将讨论为什么会这样，以及我们如何能够重建那块肌肉，我们如何能够重新听到，我不知道什么，什么才是正确的词，在我们短休之后，我们如何能够重新调回这个我们所有人天生都拥有的自我知识和自我信任的深泉。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信籽油本质上是会引起炎症的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，成为一个更快乐、更充实、
healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
更健康的人。收听《2%》，即数字 2%，可在 I-Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候做得够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上时做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，探讨。关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标真实对话，尽在我的新播客《知难而进》。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard way”，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，旨在证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's strength. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Marantini.
你曾两次在某人的力量下篡改了这个特定的测试。我篡改过测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱平（Greg Lepin）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Amaricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临着后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 Iheart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with. her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh hell no. I vowed. I will be his last
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡村女孩。自作聪明，自食其果。规则二，千万别惹。她的朋友们。我们总是说相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定亲自采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个
target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that
目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。可在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说
George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down. and try to make sense of how we survived it.
乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么狗屁关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情。并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近的一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈特谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think if we want to learn how to implement self-trust into our lives, we need to first really understand what that actually looks and feels like. I think it can be tricky to describe because unlike external trust where you can kind of assess how reliable someone is by past performance, sometimes we aren't as objective with ourselves. So here's your kind of guide to, I guess, what it feels like. Firstly, self-trust means following through on promises. If you say you'll stop work at 6pm,
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。我认为，如果我们想学会如何在生活中践行自我信任，我们需要首先真正理解这实际上看起来和感觉起来是什么样的。我认为这可能很难描述，因为不像外部信任，你可以通过过去的表现来评估某人的可靠性，有时我们对自己的看法并不那么客观。所以这里是你的指南，我想，关于它是什么感觉。首先，自信意味着兑现承诺。如果你说你下午 6 点停止工作，
you actually do it. If you commit to calling your friend because they matter to you, you follow through. If you set a goal, if you set a boundary for your well-being, whether that's blocking someone saying no to a draining event, knowing when you need to take a break, you don't abandon yourself for the sake of approval. You really understand that you are the one who understands yourself the most. A really famous psychologist, Carl Rogers, he described this as congruence, which is basically when what you feel on the inside aligns with how you show up on the outside. This is less about perfectionism, it's less about consistency, it's less about control, the knowledge that you can count on yourself the same way maybe even more than you want to count on
你真的做到了。如果你承诺给你的朋友打电话，因为他们对你很重要，你会说到做到。如果你设定了一个目标，如果你为自己的福祉设定了一条界限，无论是屏蔽某人、对消耗精力的活动说不、知道什么时候你需要休息，你都不会为了迎合别人的赞许而放弃自己。你真正明白你是那个最了解自己的人。一位非常著名的心理学家卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers），他将此描述为“全人一致”（congruence），这基本上就是你内心的感受与你外在的表现相一致的时候。这较少关于完美主义，较少关于一致性，较少关于控制，而是一种认知：你可以指望自己，就像甚至比你想要指望
others is just like this very deeply stable calm feeling that like there is someone who has your back and that person is you. I think self-trust actually I know self-trust also feels like compassion think about it if you constantly punish yourself when things go wrong, which they will. Why would you ever risk trying again? If you keep beating yourself up when you make a mistake because you literally didn't know any better, that doesn't sound like someone who trusts that they're going to be okay, even if it's not right now, but in the end. Self-trust, if you want to build it, it looks like speaking to yourself with the same tone you would use with a really close friend or with, you know, your baby sister or with your childhood self.
另一种感觉就像是一种非常深厚、稳定且平静的感觉，就好像有人在支持你，而那个人就是你自己。我认为自我信任——其实我知道，自我信任也带有一种同理心。你想想看，如果你在事情出错时总是惩罚自己（而事情是一定会出错的），你为什么还要冒险再去尝试呢？如果你在犯错时总是不断地自我责备，仅仅因为你当时确实不知道更好的做法，这听起来可不像是一个相信自己最终会好起来的人——哪怕现在还没好，但最终结果会是好的。自我信任，如果你想建立它，它的表现形式就是用对待一个真正的好朋友，或者对待你的小妹妹，又或是对待你童年时的自己的那种语气来和自己说话。
instead of saying like oh my god i should have known better i'm such an idiot this was like totally avoidable it's more like saying yeah that was really hard and this is a great opportunity to learn and in those self-directed moments of gentleness you deepen that bond the way that a child would respond to gentle parenting or like someone who lets them make errors and therefore allows them to test their boundaries more allows them to trust themselves more because they know they are in safe company the world can be really critical and really judgmental. Like, if you're looking for someone to hate on you,
而不是说：“天哪，我本该知道更好的做法，我真是个白痴，这完全是可以避免的。”它更像是说：“是的，那真的很艰难，这是一个很好的学习机会。”在那些自我主导的温柔时刻，你加深了那种纽带，就像一个孩子会对温和的育儿方式做出反应一样，或者像一个允许他们犯错、从而允许他们更多地测试自己边界的人那样，这能让他们更信任自己，因为他们知道自己身处安全的陪伴之中。这个世界可能会非常苛刻，充满评判。就像，如果你在找一个会讨厌你的人，
if you're looking for someone to tear you down, you can find someone like that pretty easily. So let someone else take care of the harshness. Let someone else be your bully. The least that we can do for ourselves is to have our own backs. Self-trust gives you the freedom, I think, to make choices without guaranteeing outcomes or demanding guarantees.
如果你在找一个会打击你的人，你很容易就能找到这样的人。所以，让别人去承担那些严厉吧。让别人去当你的恶霸吧。我们能为自己做的最起码的事情，就是支持我们自己。我认为，自我信任赋予了你一种自由，让你能够在不保证结果、也不要求保证的情况下做出选择。
Imagine, like, you're standing in front of two job offers. This is actually an example that was given to me by a listener at one of our live shows recently where she asked me. You know, I've got these two job offers. I've just graduated university. One is super safe and predictable. One is really risky, but it's super exciting. She was talking about how she's kind of been sitting on these offers for over a month out of fear that she would make the wrong choice. Out of fear that that wrong choice would then spiral and ruin her life.
想象一下，你正站在两个工作机会面前。这其实是一位听众最近在我们的一场现场演出中给我的一个例子，她当时问我。你知道，我有这两个工作机会。我刚大学毕业。一份工作超级稳定、可以预测。另一份工作风险很高，但超级令人兴奋。她谈到自己因为害怕做出错误的选择，已经拿着这些offer纠结了一个多月。害怕那个错误的选择会像滚雪球一样毁了她的人生。
Trust me, it's actually harder to ruin your life. life than you think. And really, like what I said to her was that not making a decision is the worst decision that you can make. The thing is, is that the fact that you care so much shows that even if you make the so-called wrong choice, you are still going to be able to act on your future interest in like a way that will guarantee you will come back to the right choice. What I mean by that is that you obviously care a lot about your life and you care a lot about making it a good life. So it's not like that's going to go away and disappear just because you make a choice that maybe wasn't right. Also, there's no way of knowing if the other choice would have been better,
相信我，其实毁掉你的人生比你想象的要难。说真的，我对她说的是，不做决定才是你能做出的最糟糕的决定。关键在于，你在乎到这种程度，这表明即使你做出了所谓的错误选择，你仍然能够以一种确保你最终会回到正确选择上的方式，去根据你未来的利益采取行动。我的意思是，你显然非常在乎自己的人生，并且非常在乎把它过好。所以，不会仅仅因为你做了一个或许并不正确的选择，这种在乎就消失不见了。而且，根本没有办法知道另一种选择是不是会更好，
but say you're really unhappy in the risky job. Say you're really unhappy in the safe job. That's not the end of your options. That's not the end of your ability to change things or to make a different decision. You are going to be okay because you have that sense of investment and care. because you trust yourself. You trust that you will not abandon yourself. That's perhaps, you know, the deepest sign of self-trust. It's resilience. That's really what I'm describing.
但假设你在那份高风险的工作中真的很不开心。假设你在那份安全的工作中真的很不开心。这并不是你选择的终点。这并不是你改变现状或做出不同决定的能力的的终点。你会没事的，因为你有那种投入感和在乎之心，因为你信任自己。你相信自己不会抛弃自己。这也许就是，你知道的，自我信任最深层的标志。它是韧性。这正是我所描述的。
Resilience. There is a developmental psychologist, and I cannot remember her name, but she calls resilience ordinary magic. You know, it's not superhuman. It's not, like, the while to come by, very regular normal people recover a, grow from decisions that didn't work out in their favor all the time.
韧性。有一位发展心理学家，我不记得她的名字了，她把韧性称为“平常的魔法”。你知道的，它不是超能力。它不是那种难得一见的东西，非常普通、正常的人们一直在从那些对他们不利、没有按预期发展的决定中恢复过来并从中成长。
And having resilience is kind of just having the ability to just acknowledge a bad outcome, acknowledge that it sucks and say, okay, is ruminating on this and obsessing over this actually going to change anything or help me? Probably not. The best way I can learn from this, the best way I can move on is to integrate what I've learned, retune that deep intuition that I have. retune or, you know, in hindsight, rethink about the signs that were there or weren't there and keep trying. I think as well, and I keep saying this, but I just want to reinforce it.
拥有韧性其实就像是拥有这样一种能力：承认一个糟糕的结果，承认它很糟糕，然后说：“好吧，反复琢磨这件事情、对它念念不忘，真的能改变什么或帮助到我吗？”大概不能。我从中学习的最佳方式、我继续前行的最佳方式，是整合我学到的东西，重新调整我内心深处的那个直觉。重新调整，或者，你知道的，在事后反思那些曾经存在或不存在的迹象，然后继续尝试。我也觉得，我一直在说这个，但我只是想强化这一点。
Self-trust is really just a sense of calm. And that's why I think that it is the opposite of anxiety. anxiety, anxiety wants to like shift everything into high gear and it wants you to get somewhere as fast as possible. It wants you to get the answers as fast as possible. And if it doesn't feel like you're moving, well, it's going to put a bit of a spark in you to do that. And I think that's where, like, a lot of that, you know, very quintessential anxiety, anxious feeling comes from. It wants to rush you. It wants you to be urgent. It wants you to just, like, figure things out, even if it's not the best decision for you. Self-trust feels like calm in comparison. It really is a physical sensation of just, like, feeling, like, your feet
自我信任实际上只是一种平静感。这就是为什么我认为它是焦虑的反义词。焦虑，焦虑想要把一切都推向最高档，它希望你尽快到达某个地方。它希望你尽快得到答案。如果你感觉自己没有在前进，好吧，它就会在你心里点燃一把火来催促你。我认为，许多那种非常典型的焦虑、焦虑不安的感觉就是这样产生的。它想要催促你。它希望你觉得事情十万火急。它希望你赶快把事情搞清楚，哪怕那并不是对你最好的决定。相比之下，自我信任的感觉是平静的。它确实是一种身体上的感觉，就像感觉到你的双脚
firmly planted, feeling like you're going to be okay, feeling like you do have some kind of like invisible armor, not against the bad things, but against being sunk by those bad things. So the good news is that self-trust isn't something you either have or you don't have. It's not something you're born with. It's not like some genetic blessing. Like we said, it's ordinary magic and it's something that you can build. it through you know daily choices through small experiments through conscious reflection even when it might bring up some hard stuff that you don't want to look at i think something really helpful to get us back in touch with this internal compass compass and our self-trust is again just to like check back in
稳稳地扎根，感觉到你会没事的，感觉到你确实拥有某种隐形的铠甲——不是为了抵御坏事，而是为了防止被那些坏事击垮。所以好消息是，自我信任并不是一种“要么你有、要么你没有”的东西。它不是天生带来的。它不像是什么基因上的祝福。就像我们说的，它是平常的魔法，是你可以通过日常的选择、通过小的实验、通过有意识的反思来建立的东西——哪怕这可能会带来一些你不想去面对的困难事情。我认为，有什么东西真的很有帮助，能让我们重新与这个内在的指南针以及我们的自我信任建立联系，那就是再次去核对
with your intuition instead of jumping into a choice pause acknowledge the anxiety or acknowledge the indecision and just ask yourself what does my gut tell me in this in this moment is the right move and what is an even deeper part of myself tell me about my abilities and my capabilities even if it isn't when you face a decision take a minute take a few days even if this is for something as small as what you want for dinner or what activity you want to do that day write down your initial instinct step away from it for a second come back to it and perhaps act on it before you seek external advice And see what the consequences are. See, like, learn from the consequences instead of seeing the consequences as punishment.
你的直觉。不要一头扎进一个选择中，先停顿一下，承认焦虑，或者承认这种犹豫不决，然后问问自己：在此时此刻，我的直觉告诉我正确的做法是什么？我内心更深处的部分关于我的能力和潜能又告诉我什么？即使现在还不是时候。当你面临一个决定时，花上一分钟，甚至几天，哪怕这只是关于你想吃晚饭吃什么，或者你想在那天进行什么活动的这样的小事。写下你的最初直觉，稍微走开一会儿，然后再回来，也许在寻求外部建议之前就根据它采取行动。然后看看结果如何。看看，从结果中学习，而不是把结果视为惩罚。
Think about the reasons that you often trust others. It's likely that the reason you do is because they're kind, because they're consistent, because they keep promises, because they show up for you. These are all things that we need to start doing for ourselves. Start with some super small, simple promises that you can make to yourself. If you've been wanting to get fit up, promise yourself that you, you will go to the gym twice a week or that you will go on one run this week. This is something that I've
想想你通常信任别人的原因。很可能是因为他们善良，因为他们言行一致，因为他们信守承诺，因为他们在你需要时陪伴在你身边。这些都是我们需要开始为自己做的事情。从你可以对自己许下的那些超级小、超级简单的承诺开始。如果你一直想保持健康，向自己保证你一周去两次健身房，或者本周去跑步一次。这是我
been doing a lot. I'm training for like a half marathon at the moment. And you know what? It's not very fun. I actually really don't enjoy it as much as I thought I was going to. But I made a commitment. And it has been like this beautiful exercise and being like, okay, I'm going to follow through with things that I decide to do the same way that I would want someone else to follow through if they had made a promise to me. keep the promise. Keep the promise. Don't let yourself down. Don't let yourself feel less worthy of your time and your energy than someone else. You know, by having this kind of respect for ourselves in these small ways,
一直在做的事情。我目前正在训练跑半程马拉松。你知道吗？这其实没那么有趣。我真的没有像自己想象的那样享受它。但我做出了一承诺。这就像是一次美妙的练习，让我觉得：“好吧，我要践行自己决定要做的事情，就像我希望别人对我做出承诺时也能践行一样。”信守承诺。信守承诺。不要让自己失望。不要让自己觉得你的时间和精力比别人更不值得。你知道的，通过在这些小事上对自己保持这种尊重，
we do really start to strengthen the narrative that like us and our unconscious or our subconscious, us and the parts that sometimes actually want to act against us, we are a team. We can work together. We can make things happen and we can survive the things that we didn't necessarily want to happen, but happened anyways. Next come the small scale experiments. I always say this and I will continue to do so. Life is not a recipe.
我们确实开始强化这样一种叙事：我们和我们的无意识或潜意识，我们与那些有时实际上想要与我们作对的部分，我们是一个团队。我们可以一起工作。我们可以让事情发生，我们能够挺过那些我们不一定想让它们发生、但最终还是发生了的事情。接下来是小规模的实验。我总是这么说，而且我将继续这么说。生活不是食谱。
I think that there is this, when you think about how life is sometimes described, it definitely has this like A to B to C idea. Like you do this and then once you've done that, you do that. And then once you've done that, you do this. And like there is a right way to go about. things. No, it's not a recipe. It's a series of experiments. It's a series of experiments where you are the subject. And whether these things work out or not, it doesn't matter. Like, it still teaches us things. Sometimes, like, the most successful experiments in science are the ones that don't work out because both of those outcomes contain information. So you need to be
我认为有这样一种现象：当你思考生活有时是如何被描述时，它绝对带有一种“A到B到C”的观念。就像你做了这件事，一旦你做完了那个，你就做那个。一旦你做完了那个，你就做这个。并且好像有一条正确的方法去做事情。不，生活不是食谱。它是一系列实验。它是一系列以你为实验对象的实验。无论这些实验结果如何，这都不重要。因为，它仍然在教给我们东西。有时，科学中最成功的实验反而是那些没有成功的实验，因为这两种结果都包含信息。所以你需要
experimenting. You need to be seeing, like, your life is a series of smaller chapters and opportunities to redirect yourself rather than just this one long, linear, continuous line where, you know, you have to make the right decision every single step of the way, otherwise the line is broken. Totally not the case. Self-trust, I think, really grows in active practice. I think it can be super helpful to choose low-stakes decisions where you can follow through on your instincts or just test them, trying new places, even if you don't know if it's going to be good, deciding when to leave an event, speaking up in a meeting when you feel like,
去实验。你需要把你的生活看作是一系列较小的章节和重新调整方向的机会，而不是一条漫长的、线性的、连续的直线，在这条线上，你知道的，你在每一步都必须做出正确的决定，否则这条线就断了。完全不是这样的。我认为，自我信任确实是在积极的实践中生长的。选择那些风险较低的决定会非常有帮助，在这些决定中你可以遵循你的直觉或者仅仅是测试它们：尝试新的地方，即使你不知道它是否会好；决定什么时候离开一个活动；在会议中当你感觉到
that pull in your chest to do so doing things you'd normally, you know, want to do with someone else doing them alone and being like, hey, I survived. This whole process is about really gaining and gathering evidence of how capable you truly are. Remember, your comfort zone feels safe because it's predictable because, again, it satisfies the need for control. It's easy to control an environment, whether it's emotional or physical, that you already like understand every inch of. but it's also where your growth will stagnate. And I'm going to take an educated guess and say that you wouldn't be listening to this episode if you were actually happy staying stagnant.
胸口有那种想要开口的冲动时勇敢发言；做那些你通常会想和别人一起做的事情，独自去完成它们，然后感叹：“嘿，我挺过来了。”整个过程实际上就是为了获得和收集关于你到底有多大能力的证据。记住，你的舒适区之所以感觉安全，是因为它是可预测的，因为同样地，它满足了对控制的需求。去控制一个你已经了解其每一寸土地的环境（无论是情感上的还是物理上的）是很容易的，但这也是你的成长会停滞不前的地方。而且我可以做一个有根据的猜测，如果你真的很满足于停滞不前，你大概就不会听这一集节目了。
Like, that's not why you're here. Our expansion zone is where true learning and true self-trust happens. It's a space of discomfort. It's also totally necessary to grow. The way we move into this zone is, again, through microactions. something I always say about risks is that they don't necessarily have to be spontaneous and large to still be expansive and to still be a risk. You don't need to quit your job and move across the world to show that you can trust yourself.
就像，你来这里不是为了这个。我们的拓展区才是真正的学习和真正的自我信任发生的地方。它是一个充满不适的空间。但它对于成长来说也绝对是必要的。我们进入这个区的方式，同样是通过微行动。关于风险，我总是说的一点是，它们不一定非得是突发的、巨大的，才能依然具有拓展性、依然算得上风险。你不需要辞掉工作并搬到世界另一端来证明你可以信任自己。
Again, just start with something small. Start with something small that you may also know won't work out so that you can kind of, again, as an experiment, see how you will still survive. see how even though you didn't know the outcome, the outcome was not as bad as you probably suspected. I also think something really crucial to add to this is to stop explaining yourself when you make either small or big decisions that feel intuitively correct to you. Fight the need to explain it to family, to colleagues, to friends, to people you don't even know. you know, I had this experience the other day where, I think I've talked about this a little bit, me and my boyfriend are moving overseas soon. We're moving to London. And it was my mom's 60th on the weekend,
同样地，从一件小事开始。从一件你甚至可能知道不会成功的小事开始，这样一来，同样地，你可以作为一个实验，看看你是如何依然能够挺过来的。看看尽管你不知道结果，但结果并没有你想象的那么糟。我还认为，对此需要补充的一个真正关键点是：当你做出在直觉上对你而言是正确的小决定或大决定时，停止向别人解释。克制向家人、同事、朋友甚至陌生人解释的冲动。你知道的，我前几天就有过这样的经历，我想我之前也稍微聊过这个，我和我男友很快就要搬到海外去了。我们要搬去伦敦。周末是我妈妈的60岁生日，
and we were in Melbourne for that. And one of her friends who I love, she's a close family friend, but one of her friends, like, was talking to me and she was kind of drilling me on like, well, why are you moving to London? Doesn't like everyone kind of do that? Like, what's your plan? Do you have a plan? Like, do you know where you're going to live? Like, what if you can't find anywhere where to live? Like, what if you don't like it and you need to come home? Like, have you thought about that? And I just felt trapped in having to explain something. You know, I don't even know if it's going to turn out right yet. But I trust that if it doesn't, I'm going to be okay. And I trust that this is where I want to be. And it immediately got me, you know, A, very defensive and B, very insecure and in
我们在墨尔本庆祝生日。我的一位我很喜欢的长辈——她是一位亲密的家庭朋友——在和我聊天时，她有点在盘问我：“嗯，你为什么要搬去伦敦？难道不是每个人都差不多会那样做吗？你的计划是什么？你有计划吗？你知道你要住在哪里吗？如果你找不到住的地方怎么办？如果你不喜欢它、需要回家怎么办？你想过这些吗？”我当时觉得自己被困住了，不得不去解释某些事情。你知道的，我甚至还不知道这最终是不是对的。但我相信，如果不对的话，我会没事的。我相信这就是我想去的地方。这立刻让我变得：A，非常防备；B，非常没有安全感，陷入了
like a state of doubting myself. And afterwards, I was talking to my cousin, who is wise beyond her years. And she was like, you should have just said, I don't know yet. But I'm not. I'm excited to find out and left it at that. Like, why did you feel like, you know, I think what she said was like the fact that you, like, in your act of explaining it to this person, maybe you were trying to explain it and justify it for yourself, but you don't need to because you already have that intuition and intention and does neither do that. And that is literally all you need.
自我怀疑的状态。事后，我和我表妹聊天，她年纪轻轻却充满智慧。她说：“你当时应该直接说：‘我还不知道。但我很高兴去探索答案。’然后就此打住就行了。”就像，你为什么会觉得——我想她说的话意思是，你在向这个人解释的过程中，也许你是在试图向自己解释和证明，但你其实不需要这样做，因为你已经有了那种直觉和意图，这就足够了。而这字面意思上就是你所需要的一切。
No one needs to know your reasons, especially since you're the one who's going to face the outcome anyway. It's not personal. It's not meant to shut them down. it's meant to protect your ability to hear your desires and feel directed by your compass. It really is, you know, so marvelous when you let yourself be a little bit afraid and so marvelous when you let yourself make a decision that you don't know, you don't know the outcome of and you still show up for that. And I know I'm using like a lot of therapy speak and a lot of like
没有人需要知道你的理由，尤其是因为无论如何要面对结果的人是你自己。这不是针对个人的。这并不是为了让别人闭嘴。这是为了保护你倾听自己欲望、并感受到被你的内心指南针指引的能力。真的，当你允许自己感到一点点害怕时，那是多么美妙；当你允许自己做一个你不知道最终结果的决定、却依然为此付出行动时，那也是多么美妙。我知道我用了大量的心理学话术和很多
self-help language. I think the real thing is that you, you know, don't really understand the brilliance of self-trust until you really experienced a moment where you're in a situation where you really can't trust anything else or you really can't trust anyone else and you just have to be the one who like is fully there for you and fully says like I'm going to be okay and I'm going to be okay even if this is like a complete mess around even if this is like a complete explosion I am grounded in my confidence I am grounded in the fact that sometimes I don't know how capable I am until there is a situation that stretches me to my limits. And then that's like my new, that's my new level, right?
自助语言。我认为真正的情况是，你（你知道的）并不真正理解自我信任的 brilliance（卓越），直到你真正经历过这样一个时刻：你处于一种你真的无法信任任何其他东西、或者你真的无法信任任何其他人的境地，你只能依靠那个全力支持自己、坚定地说出“我会没事的，即使这是一团糟、即使这是一场彻底的爆发，我也会没事的，我扎根于我的自信之中，我扎根于这样一个事实：有时我并不了解自己的极限，直到有一种情况把我拉伸到了极限”的人。然后那就是我的新水平，对吧？
Like that's my new, that's my new threshold. And then something else will, and then by being in that threshold, there's like a whole new, a whole new like environment of opportunities that become available. And once you've mastered those, like another level will open up by you extending yourself and by you saying, I'm going to be okay. I'm going to be okay in this. I trust myself. I trust my abilities.
就像那是我的新门槛。然后会有别的事情发生，而通过处于那个门槛，就会有一个全新的、充满机遇的环境变得触手可及。一旦你掌握了这些，通过不断拓展自己并对自己说“我会没事的，我在这种情况下会没事的，我信任自己，我信任自己的能力”，另一个层次就会为你打开。
I trust my intuition. And the more you like operate with that manual in mind and the more you operate with that perspective, like the stronger and stronger this muscle becomes until, I don't know, I feel like you're willing to make risks that take risks at the drop of the hat. You're willing to leave situations you don't want to be in. You are willing to leave relationships you don't want to be in, friendships you don't want to be in, jobs you don't want to be in because you know that something better will come along or that you'll be able to create that better situation for yourself.
我信任我的直觉。你越是带着那种内心指南针去行事，你越是带着那种视角去运作，这个肌肉就会变得越来越强壮，直到，我不知道，我觉得你会随时随地都愿意去承担风险。你愿意离开你不想待的环境。你愿意离开你不想待的关系，你不想待的友谊，你不想待的工作，因为你知道会有更好的事情到来，或者你能够为自己创造那种更好的情况。
So that's just a convoluted way of saying self-trust is important. I hope that it's something that you continue to focus on. I hope that you can see it now as a bit of an antidote for a lot of what we fear and a lot of what, you know, we desperately want to cling on to, which is control uncertainty. You can't have those things, but you can have self-trust in the face of them. I want to thank our researcher Libby Colbert for her help on this episode. If this helped you, make sure you share it with a friend, share it on social media, share it, I don't know, with a parent or with a colleague, whoever. If you want to hear more about this topic, if you want to see more content like this, you can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast.
所以，这只是一种拐弯抹角的方式，来表达自我信任很重要。我希望这是你将继续关注的事情。我希望你现在能把它看作是我们所恐惧的许多事情以及我们拼命想要抓紧的东西——也就是控制和不确定性——的一种解药。你无法拥有那些东西，但面对它们时，你可以拥有自我信任。我要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的帮助。如果这帮到了你，请务必把它分享给朋友，分享到社交媒体上，分享给——我不知道——父母或同事，随便什么人。如果你想听到更多关于这个话题的内容，如果你想看到更多这样的内容，你也可以在 Instagram 上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。
people always ask me about the name. This is like a total tangent. But someone the other day was like, why is it that psychology podcast when that's not the name of your podcast? And I was like, because the psychology of your 20s was too long to like show up. So anyways, that's where you can find us.
人们总是问我这个名字的事。这完全是题外话。但前几天有人问：“为什么名字是 That Psychology Podcast，而这并不是你的播客名字？”我说：“因为‘Your 20s 的心理学’太长了，显示不全。”总之，这就是你们能找到我们的地方。
We do like these cool summaries of these episodes if you want something to refer back to as well. If you feel called to do so, leave a five-star review. Make sure you're following along or subscribed. Wherever you are listening to this episode. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Trust yourself.
如果你想要一些可以回头参考的内容，我们确实会对这些节目做这些很酷的总结。如果你觉得有共鸣，请留下一个五星好评。确保你正在关注或订阅无论你在哪里收听这期节目。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。相信你自己。
And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side,
我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇异的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将破茧成蝶，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字为“2%”。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends, Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜，听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个大日子。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何其他地方谈论都极不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人随身携带一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same. same thing. Greg, Lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
事情。格雷格·莱斯利（Greg Leslie）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人。本集尚无评论。点击转写中的任何句子即可发表评论。